interesting
yes we're recording okay
let's see
all right uh let me start with
introducing Jesse from my side first
Jesse
um this is for the recording purpose
um if you don't mind
all right good evening everybody uh
Welcome to our uh Pi data triangle Pi
data July event
um today our speaker uh is Mr Jesse
Everson and
um Jesse is currently working as a cyber
security consultant for uh image acts
Consulting uncontracted to AIG where he
served as a team lead in cyber security
vulnerability management
uh Jesse is a career software engineer
and I.T manager whose experience with
data science began by integrating
predictive modeling Technologies into
marketing campaign management platforms
following his work in marketing
analytics Jesse began working in the
data intensive discipline of cyber
security where he currently focuses on
problems in the area of vulnerability
and management
uh Jesse holds a bachelor degree in
chemistry and Mathematics from Moorhead
State University and a master's degree
in computer science from the Georgia
Institute of Technology
extended profile can be defined later if
you're interested please contact our
triangle Pi data or we'll be happy to
supply that
all right it's all yours Mr Jesse
thank you so much
okay let's see if I can share my screen
uh
I'm not a big fan of teams let's see if
this works can you see my screen
yes we can yes sir
and so how many of y'all know Gene
farooza
I assume most of you
um
he got a hold of me and he said do you
want to do something on cyber security
and one of the things I wanted to say to
the group here is one of the things that
we care about in cyber security is
awareness
so depending on the awareness in the
group much of this is going to be about
awareness and then we can talk about
graph databases
so there's going to be more on awareness
and less on graph databases and we'll
see why later
so from an awareness point of view I
thought it would be good to let you guys
know what's going on in vulnerability
management why how
and what in a graph database technology
we can talk about graph database
technology and why a graph database and
how it might apply to vulnerability
management but I will tell you that I
think that a lot of existing products
that are out there now may be using
graph databases but traditional database
is primarily what I've seen in my
experience
at at the top of the food chain is the
common vulnerabilities and exposures
database that's maintained by minor
so for all of us you know that look at
our federal government is a central
funding agency
uh one of the things that you may or may
not know this database is Central to
just about
all of the efforts that go on in large
Enterprise
vulnerability management so what's going
to happen is if somebody
hacks a particular system that hack will
be identified it will eventually make
its way here and then you will
see that and if you're an Enterprise you
will be
uh tasked with understanding whether or
not you have that vulnerability and
whether and what to do about it so if
you think about malware and
um
ransomware and that sort of thing many
of the uh just about all of those are
associated with what a cve
and your job if you're on the inside is
to determine what cves that you have
exposed in your environment and what
you're going to do about them and that's
not necessarily an easy problem just
because you find out about it doesn't
mean that you can easily fix it
and that gets us to wow now that I know
that all these vulnerabilities exist
how do I manage what what does it mean
to manage them and I got those in this
these are my Google search uh
I've gotten tired of writing these up
myself so I just go get them off Google
uh but it is a cycle and you can imagine
that you're managing an I.T shop
and you've got to classify prioritize
mediate and mitigate because your
software is always changing you're
getting notifications of vulnerabilities
literally on a daily basis which I was
dealing with today and
um
it's an ongoing process
so it is Data intensive and and hence
you know taking a look at if I'm going
to manage banking database
model for this particular problem
how does it play out
but this is also about awareness of
cyber security and what it is we have to
go through every day in Day Out
or vulnerability management mind you the
government all Enterprises everybody has
to do this
at scale
so I went and dug out you know there are
five million different diagrams for
uh vulnerability management life cycle I
pulled this one these guys happen to be
out of uh Huntsman in Australia
some have five some have six but
literally you discover prioritize access
report remediate and verify
now and then I I added some arrows here
because verify and remediate is a it has
its own cycle and prioritize and assess
as its own cycle so they didn't put that
in there so I added that because I know
that's there
um
Discovery is from multiple sources so
researchers uh the government
announcements from Microsoft uh you know
there's countless different sources from
where you can discover that day that you
now there is a new vulnerability to Any
Given system on any given software in
your environment
and and
uh
it's like watching the news every day I
I mean it's like intelligence
so the question is because you get a
bunch of these coming in in every day
what's the risk because they you know
how many are you getting how much how
you know what's a risk how do I deal
with it
evaluate the scope
um you've got a report on it and that
depends on your
um the size of your organization but you
really need I mean
it's like the White House intelligence
briefing every day almost uh it
certainly is for me right now because
that I sit in those briefings
remediate okay uh how am I going to fix
this thing now that I know about it
where is it and what am I going to do
and uh well then how do I verify that I
got it fixed I mean just because
somebody says it fit it's fixed uh do I
check on them and that's kind of like
regression
and it it's not
unbelievable you know what I can tell
you is you can always introduce an old
vulnerability into anybody's environment
in today's modern uh virtual environment
by using a image from say a Linux or
Windows uh image that you've got and
they let you put it in their little hat
and you put it on the network and it's
got a vulnerability in it so continuous
verification is a part of this game it's
it's it's just the way it works
Jesse yes
um that brings to mind it reminds me of
uh automated testing and test cases are
you going to speak to to that later on
or we can invite you back for for
testing yeah I mean we're getting we're
starting to go down a rabbit hole on
that okay so
but when you talk about automated tests
we'll talk about that later keep that in
mind and remind me
okay in terms of automated test cases
because that's more on the development
side
in the area of what we call sast and
vast
where we test software or whether it has
vulnerabilities
but what if we get software in from a
third-party vendor in a in a supply
chain
how do we detect vulnerabilities there
and we'll talk about that
okay
so
that that plays into these use cases
here you know sisa orders agencies to
patch Windows LSA bug
these come in every day so this one came
in on the first of July
uh multiple vulnerabilities in Google
Chrome all right so you're deploying
Chrome across your Enterprise how do you
get it patched across all your
um
endpoints in your Enterprise or Google
Chrome is and I couldn't resist this one
where Pi Pi python packages called
sending stolen AWS keys to unscared
sites
and that was was in June so late June so
okay so what I got to do to run that
down in an Enterprise of 150 000
endpoints and who's using python
and who's using Pi Pi I bet some of you
guys are
so so
if I'm the security guy and I come over
to you and say hey you need you've got
you know I found that your machine has
you know we'll talk about how I found
that out later but uh you got
uh compromised or a vulnerability on
your python Library it's on your machine
you need to go patch
and so I thought uh this one came out
yesterday and is on the radar screen uh
both of these uh
Microsoft has what they call Patch
Tuesday and they do it every month
and so they come out and you get a
bucket uh patches
and then the organization is
saddled with how do I take all these
patches and figure out how to get them
in my organization
you know do I attack in what you were
talking about I think it was Mark that
brought up the question
yes
um there are big issues with testing
because
I can't go take
a big patch list like this and deploy it
across an Enterprise and be safe so I've
got this real trade-off where uh there
could be a zero day in it like sisa cesa
came out like yesterday and basically
said we got a Windows zero day and we're
requiring all the government
uh anybody that's got windows in the
government to patch
according to this cve
so the cve is really important because
that's your key to what they're going to
attract the vulnerability against that
you need to be able to prove that you
got your patch in there and you no
longer have that vulnerability in your
system
uh it's it's it's it's it's it's an
interesting problem so these came out
yesterday
and trust me they come out every day
so large I.T departments have a big
problem with this because they've got
all of their software running
uh
any one of these patches that they put
in could break their software
and so how like how much time does it
take to test
and how can they figure out whether the
song whether this patch is going to
break their software
wait I will we'll save that conversation
for later but you you get where I'm
going with that
so when you get one of these and you're
in this cycle
what's my risk exposure is one of the
big questions so one of the things that
we're looking at is evaluating uh is how
easy is it is it externally facing is it
only on the inside behind the firewall
uh how many of them had it where because
in a larger Enterprise
that you know it depends on where the
vulnerability is so it's it's it's a
complex problem
and uh again how do I know for sure if I
do where are they how do I fix them that
that's a huge problem
and how do I verify that they are fixed
because it only takes one to be open
because the hacker gets into your
environment then they can scan your
entire environment and once these cves
get released into the open
all the bad guys know about them
so uh let's just say a researcher goes
out and says hey I found this
vulnerability and some those are often
called proof of Concepts
and then we have what's called is it has
been exploited in the wild
so once something's been exploited in
the wild which means is some China
Russia Whoever has figured it out it's
on the dark web you're exposed
and whatever attack that they want to do
they're going to exploit the
vulnerability and then deploy whatever
payload that they have but and usually
they exploit a payload or a
vulnerability to deploy a valence
sorry payload if now if I fix them how
do I verify they have not returned and
what I'm the reason I put that in there
is because
again we deploy images
in the virtual environment now
that we don't pay close attention to
that
um regress the system
so they've got vulnerabilities and
images and this is a known problem where
uh I'm not keeping good track of all the
images that allow my Engineers to deploy
in my environment and they're not
scanned well boom I'm putting them out
connecting them to the network
and they got known vulnerabilities in
them if you've got a bad guy around they
they
you're exposed
so I thought I would put up a diagram of
a home network to give you some idea
and it's a psych I'll look at this and I
go wow what if I wanted to collect data
from all these devices put them in a
database somewhere and then try to
figure out if they have vulnerabilities
in them
so
we use this diagram previously for how
to
you know use firewalls
to protect against uh video games
with my son but each and every one of
these devices you see here uh can be
reporting data
into a central database
such a you can analyze that data and
then
try to determine
uh the first thing what we're going to
look for is vulnerability so you're
going to want to look for what software
do you have on it uh and look back to
the central databases and compare that
against whether you have a vulnerability
or not and then tell you okay
you're flagged
you need fixes and it could be on any
one of these devices and it could be
anything on those devices
and it could have a severity associated
with it
in terms of how hard it is to be able to
exploit that vulnerability
so as you might imagine there are uh has
been no shortage of vendors that operate
in the space at the Enterprise level
this is just a sample of them but these
are some of the bigger ones
uh qualis in particular servicenow
you guys may know about uh service now
is uh IBM product and what they are used
for primarily is
um what we call a configuration
management database
it's a lot of this has to do with Asset
Management so that you know all the
devices you have deployed
uh can I got bought out by Cisco but
what they do is they also get
information on what
the risk is if they find a vulnerability
titanium is a device it does fall
Integrity management and remote uh code
execution on your devices but it knows
what you've got on your machine quality
studs their code is a
um
software analysis tool that knows about
what your software is and can analyze it
for
vulnerabilities that can be detected by
doing scans of source code that's what
bear code does Palo Alto is firewall
company but they also are able to give
you information on your network and how
your network is laid out printable is
equivalent to koalas tripwire
is a configuration management tool and
bit site is one of these guys that goes
out and analyzes externally and actually
publishes a score on your company as far
as to what ports and much if you guys
hear thunder and stuff in the background
um bits I
is a company that actually rates your
security with regard to your externally
facing interface to the Internet so
they will scan you and give you a score
and say hey you're
you're not very secure or you are secure
hey Jesse
um sorry to be interrupt uh but we do
have one question pop up in the chat if
you don't mind uh do you feel like
go all the way to the to the end of the
presentation or it's okay for people to
ask questions in a way oh no yeah go
ahead raise the question sure sure I'll
read this question
um
does Jesse have any recommended size to
keep informed on these issues for people
that are interested but do not always
dive into the cve database
offhand what Taylor Taylor was the one
who asked this question so Taylor
enjoyed looking at uh
creeps some Crips and security.com and
dark reading.com
so any recommendations
and let me make sure I understand that
uh
I don't know if I know the exact answer
to you are you asking for my
recommendation
Hey sir are you there can you hear me
yeah yeah so we we can wait till the end
but I guess I'm just curious in terms of
like for people who are interested in
cyber security and these cves but like
you know want to keep informed but don't
necessarily um
you know uh it's another day-to-day life
kind of thing in terms of like just
general like websites like aggregate
websites but we can wait till the end if
you have some recommendations
well I have a what I call Trade rags and
it depends on what your objective is but
I have a collection of about 12 to 13
trade rags
you know in the old days
hopefully you're you may have heard that
Thunder
um
and uh if you want to stay up to date on
the latest stuff
uh these this collection of web you know
I hadn't thought about that you brought
up a good point
I can publish that I can give you guys
links to all of these websites they're
all public and uh
if you want to look at them every day
and they
they cover a lot of different things so
and some of them stamped today on the
latest and some of them uh talk about
other topics a lot of times I'm mostly
concerned about what the latest
vulnerability is uh and how it affects
me uh that a lot of times they'll be
talking about you know some fishing
campaign or whether
uh
what China group it you know the various
names all Hacker groups and all that
stuff if that's what you're interested
in
this group
um links will I hadn't thought about
that but if you want that group of links
I can make it available all right yeah
I'd be interested in it thanks
yeah
is that what you were after something
like that yeah that's exactly where I'm
after is like basically someone who's in
in your domain that like what what you
read kind of thing so oh yeah oh yeah
hmm
well this group of links I mean will
keep you busy
if you wake up in the morning every day
and you start going through it it'll
keep you busy
so
now from a database point of view this
is a very simple diagram that I
assembled
you know I could complicate it off the
you know the chart
but
I mean I can apply this to
generally to any problem but all of
these applications that we use in
vulnerability management all have
databases
and one of the problems with them is
that
you know they're their own database they
don't work together with each other and
they don't have interfaces so what
you'll find when you get in these
Enterprises is
everybody does an ETL over to the
central data store and they use some bi
reporting tool
which is okay now that you're in that
Central data store
how you going to store that data
because I'm going to assemble all this
data so
let's take a look here
what see if I know how to go back
oops
sorry about that guys
no worries take your time
he stopped here for a second
I hit the wrong button folks
that's all right Jesse
I see uh
Dave commented on the um uh some some
codes that he was using uh for
vulnerability detecting
um
uh Dave is using HP
45
SCA to scan some of his code for
vulnerability
I think that's one of the best practices
in Google Dave
I'm having technical problems here
it again is Dave online
it in in terms of software scanners is
is that what he's talking about
yes I think Dave was talking about the
um uh
the HP the HP uh 45
fortify yeah so Vera code fortified
take your pick
with regard to if you're going to do
what is the software application
security
uh it's sassed
so dast is dynamic after you do it is my
screen off now
um
or can you see my screen
not yet Jesse okay hold on
let's chance okay
yeah
um
how about now yeah we can't see yourself
yeah so with regard to
when you're a developer and you're
building code
and let's just say you're going to
release it into a production environment
in an Enterprise
these days
um you're going to run it through
somebody's uh SAS scanner
if if you've got a reasonable you know
security environment installed and the
reason for that is is because developers
may not be security conscious
so what will happen is when you go
through these scanners they will come
back and say hey you you can get a SQL
code in Jack
injection vulnerability here or
cross-site scripting or that kind of
thing so the technology is Advanced to
the point to where software code
scanners uh software
code like you know and they look for
like anything that tries to pick up the
password or that kind of thing so
yeah that's that's moved along pretty
far I mean it's not perfect but it's
it's a lot better and the thing is is
that you want to go through one of the
scanners
and you want to put it in the hands of
the developers ahead of time to say hey
you just go scan this stuff yourself
before you give it to me because you're
going to have to go through a gate to be
able to get your code into production
because the the bad answer did that make
sense
yes yes Jesse it does thank you for that
the the particular white hats one of
them I mean there's there's several SAS
tools that are out there and that you
know depends on who you can probably go
find some open source ones that you know
will scan your code if you don't have a
lot of money to pay some of these big
guys
uh so it depends on the size of your
Enterprise and that thing if you're
going to do SAS but I recommend it to
anybody you know just go get an open
source one if you want to release some
code
out on the net to have it look at it you
know and now I haven't gone out and done
a scan on I I bet some of them will
actually do it online and make you sign
up and everything and then try to give
you a scan of your code
but that's kind of uh what they'll do is
they will tell you if your software has
a vulnerability
what's interesting about that is this is
code that you just wrote
and it's got a vulnerability in it so
what would happen is if you release that
code in production it would end up being
a zero day
somebody comes along you're sitting on
an API port
somebody's going to hit that port
and you know send you some stuff that
you're not prepared for
you're going to have a zero day event
if that makes sense
and they know how to do that trust me
so with the back to this diagram
you've got a central database how is it
organized
me personally right now at the level I
work at I don't care but we'll get into
that but
I need my questions answered
so there are a lot of different data
fields that we care about uh but I
wanted to keep it simple here
and if I had if you know I'd say pick
four you know what pills do you care
about
um I I and when I use the term endpoint
what I mean is anything that's connected
on your network
I use the term endpoint that's what
tanium uses some people call them
servers
some people call them workstations
uh
but
you can't mobile devices
anything that's connected to the network
is an endpoint
what software is it
who owns it
and do I have a vulnerability on that
now that I've learned that we have a
vulnerability if I got those four Fields
right there
I can go a long way in vulnerability
management and so I thought hey
all right it's SQL statement for that if
I had those on those four fields in one
table
select endpoint an owner from my
vulnerability table where vulnerability
equals CV of concern
now
all of those
products that we talked about before
have other IDs in them
and can be much more useful but I'm just
using the cve as the Central Key here
because when you go to the cve
website it will tell you what the
vulnerability is
what a risk ranking score is
and
you know generally how to fix it like
pageant
so what I want to know is
you know
do I have this vulnerability on my state
am I in point of State
that seems like a really simple SQL
statement off of a very simple table and
to be honest with you it kind of is
now when I went out and looked at
graph databases and I said why would I
organize my underlying database
and I pulled this from neo4j and it's
not related to but then I'm going to
allow people to kind of extrapolate but
when you look at
way a graph database is put together
um relationships
and properties and attributes
and you want to put a node in so you can
say well that person there that's an
endpoint
and it's connected to this other person
but and how are those endpoints
connected and the software maybe the car
who owns it
and where is the vulnerability
so I put this together pretty fast to
leave it to your eyes imagination but
what I'm going with with this if you're
going to design a vulnerability
management database
so that you will get what are you going
to get out of it well the end and I got
this from Neil for Jay as well the
endpoint has software the latest Windows
nasty bug
and owned by some person in Ukraine
foreign
so
you know that kind of statement is not
necessarily as easy
to express in a SQL statement so when I
was looking at it
I was saying well that may be some value
that a graph database
brings to this problem
and then
well
that
well you know now I have to go build a
graph database in in addition to my
traditional data warehouse which has a
bunch of tables in it
that have a bunch of Keys pointing all
over the place pointing to these
entities
so
conclusion is you know the data model is
up to the implementation engineers
do you do you need more performance in
this particular application I'm not sure
performance
is like it is in big large marketing
applications with huge databases the
databases are large but you can sit
around and wait if you get the right
data that you want
um ease of use with the right being able
to answer questions that you really need
answered is important
and a an effective query language
that you can easily communicate so you
can think about wow I need to bring some
new people into my department well how
am I going to explain this query
language
to then if it's hard to understand query
language because is it expert friendly
or you know like we used to say in Linux
oh that's expert friendly so yeah I know
the Linux command line and all that how
long does it take me to teach somebody
the Linux command line it can be a while
right
so
user interface is always an issued so if
you want to plug in some bi tool to it
uh be ready for that
um and when I looked at this and I
um
and I didn't go into trying to design
remotely design a graph data model for
the problem that I'm talking about here
but I did go to the point to say yeah
it'd take me some time to try to build
all this out after I looked at some of
the neo4j
simple examples
um
ETL to a graph data model
is always going to be a details always a
problem so you've got to get the the
data model
uh together and then figure out how
you're going to write your ETL to it so
you're likely maybe gonna have to do
that by hand I would say
at this day and age because maybe there
are some tools out there that you can
give a graph on a data model to an ETL
tool and pull it most of the
data sources that you're going to run
into in this problem space are going to
be flat tables
and you're going to have to be able to
figure out what the relationships on
those flat tables and figure out how to
tell ETL to do the right thing and build
up all your nodes in your relationships
um
integrating that between a traditional
data model I think is going to be a
challenge
and I at my
my point right now and I could be behind
on this but I think it's going to remain
a research issue while
traditional data models dominate they're
already in place
um somebody's gonna have to show some
serious value because
I don't think that we're going to see
any kind of common graph day model based
vulnerability management database
come out somebody's going to have to go
in and say Here's the value proposition
let's build one
game on
questions
comments concerns I'm done
thank you Jesse for awesome game all
presentation
um
is sour q a session if you guys would
like to ask questions we have five
minutes
so Jesse did you uh did you go ahead and
Implement a graph database
or for tracking this or did you stick
with uh
um relational database
nah I mean I work with a
massive relational database every day
that other people build
I mean they're massive all right 200 300
tables
something like that yeah
so if you're going to build a graph
database you're going to have to figure
out how to do all your nodes
in the context of that
you know a bunch of people that
done a bunch of
entity relationship diagrams between all
these essentially
products that if you do an API interface
and you do an act an extract what's
going to happen is you're going to get a
flat table right right that you would
you would put it in like an Excel
spreadsheet now you load that you you
figure out what you care about in that
and you load that into some relational
table
and then you figure out
some entity relationship from there
what what's interesting about graph is
what if I did that a little bit
different than an entity relationship
diagram in a relational
table context would I be able to get
better answers to my questions
that's what needs to be explored because
I have my data in a different
organizational model
gotcha that that that when I looked at
this problem that's what came to mind
yeah
um
I guess a comment that I have is that
neo4j does have a a substantial well
more more than one
more than one way to uh import data
whether it's flat flat CSV files or from
a a SQL Server relational database
um so there there are multiple ways of
getting uh getting your data into
um a graph database
hey I do agree I do agree with you that
you you've got to set up set up some
thought ahead of time going
what kind of nodes am I going to have
and
how will the nodes relate to each other
you know that does take some thought
does take some thought
um
but the nice thing about
um
graph databases is uh you can you can
prototype fairly rapidly with it
yeah yeah and
you know most I spend most of my time
right now asking questions rather than
designing the back end
so I'd certainly agree 100 and that you
you really sparked my interest when you
asked me to come and speak on this so in
some respects uh whoever's in the room
that knows how to do that I would love
to collaborate with them because
you know the problem space sits out at
the question level
well I'll tell you what uh since I'm on
a bit of a graph database kick in the
2022 and
20
23
um
uh time area this
this year and and part of next year uh I
I want to introduce graph data graph
databases uh and uh and then graph
database for data science to this group
I do have some contacts and I will be in
touch with you and and put you in touch
with some people who can help you
uh yeah it's a
I in my opinion it's a problem space
with regard to the underlying data data
model in the
higher level problem space
uh to explore
um I think some of the uh one of the
things
I think some of the actual tools that
are out there based on the query
languages that I'm looking at like
titanium
flawless uh when I looked at some of the
neo4j query language and stopped
I think they themselves may be using
some graph database technology for their
own database management
the the thing is is what we're doing in
vulnerability management is pulling
extracts from all those guys
so I don't care about your query
language I'm pulling
data from all these different sources
and assembling it to solve this other
greater problem based on you know the
specific
data that you have none of them have the
same data they have overlapping data but
they don't have the same data
so it you could Envision it like okay
I got five different consoles and I'm a
human being and I go to five different
consoles to answer a question and I pull
extracts when I do that from the reports
and put it into an Excel spreadsheet
and now I'll go out and do a bunch of
pivot tables
to try to get the data the way I want to
see it
and it comes from five different sources
so that is a huge problem because it is
totally manual when you need to be able
to Define this is what this is the
question I need to answer from those
five different sources do I do I pull an
extract into a node database and then
that then makes it easier for me to
answer that question
that that that's been on my mind right
and and like I said I will uh I will put
you in touch with some uh some people
who can
help you help you answer that question
I look forward to it
all righty thank you so much Jesse for
the awesome presentation
um a lot of good stuff and um new
knowledge we obtained from this session
and thank you very much for that
um if no one has more questions that's
proceed with proceed to our next
uh part of today's event yeah can I
introduce the first lightning talk
uh
I'd like to introduce Stan and I will I
will hopefully get this right Stan a
halt
um who uh is the new new Dean of the
school of data science and at Chapel
Hill
and so
Stanis Stan is here in the participants
list
I I am here and can you hear me okay I
can hear you good I'm trying to turn on
my camera but unfortunately since I
don't use well maybe that's close enough
how's that work
um
very good so I thought that was a very
interesting talk and I want to tell you
about this new school of data science
and society that we're launching at UNC
Chapel Hill and I'm hoping that you all
can both spread the word and also
um perhaps give us some advice in the
relatively near term on types of things
that we need to teach our students to be
you know very much The Cutting Edge data
scientists that we need uh you know here
in the Triangle here in the state and
here in the nation and I can tell you
that I spent
um at least two conversations today
talking about knowledge graphs so this
is an area near and dear to my heart in
an area that I definitely want to see
embedded into the curriculum of the new
school so about 10 days or so ago as I
was named the inaugural dean of the new
school of data science and Society so I
just wanted to briefly share my vision
for what we're shooting for in creating
this new school and and then open it up
to some questions I'm trying to make
sure sure I stay at five minutes so I
have been primarily focused on research
and research that's focused on large
team science efforts so we do a lot of
collaborative research with groups that
are across the country and sometimes you
know multiple continents and that was
all being done as my in my role as the
Director of Red Sea redsy is the
Renaissance Computing Institute I would
not be surprised if some of the rentsy
folks were on this this call tonight
I know there's some active participants
that from renting but um we do have a
about 100 people working at rent C it's
not a big organization but it is a
potent one and we you know we end up
doing a lot of very interesting research
for various sponsored uh research uh
research sponsors including NIH NSF DOD
Etc however I was trained as a as a a
educator so this is a full full circle
mode I'm returning to activities that I
really love and that's in particular is
reaching out and interacting with
students and so even though my research
for the last nine years has been focused
on solely on data science and making
sure that it becomes a a modern science
a keystone of modern science I'm really
very excited about this opportunity to
start a new school and start producing
the types of
undergraduates graduates Masters
students and phds that hopefully folks
here in the triangle and in the state of
North Carolina can be using uh and and
employing and I think hopefully we start
a new process in the Triangle of being
what known as one of the greatest
locations in the United States for for
data science so our objective is to
create a very unique program in data
science that focuses not just on the
fundamental science but also on the
methods and the Technologies including
things like graph databases which I
would say right now is one of the
hottest topics out in Academia and in in
industry
and and those you know the underpinnings
are the the the technologies that a lot
of us are using here in the Triangle in
different places and lots of times we
don't get to talk about it as a
collective and I hope this is an
opportunity for us to act as a
as a group that has a lot of focus on
data science so um you know we're going
to focus the the school on the breadth
of activities that are represented at
UNC Chapel Hill that's the reason we
named it the school for data science and
Society because UNC is not a
predominantly engineering school it's
more of a liberal arts university but
that does not mean that we cannot
contribute substantially to the
scientific engineering opportunities
that exist around data science so I'm
hoping that we really be in a end up
being a school that's applied
translational and convergent and uses
foundational Tech advances in theory but
also methods in technology and being
able to bring together students and
staff in the sciences and other
disciplines in the humanities that
really are uh some of the big challenges
for our society right now and
particularly data has become Central to
issues in our democracy
data's data is at the center of issues
around crime and vulnerability and
disinformation as well as opportunities
for understanding climate change and how
it might affect Health patterns so the
you know the sky's the limit here so we
are hoping over the next few years and
we're trying to do this very rapidly and
starting hiring faculty immediately as
far as I'm concerned and we're going to
try to be very inclusive about what we
mean by somebody who is a data scientist
we're not going to just pick people out
of computer science or statistics or
computational areas we're going to
include mathematics we're going to
include epidemiology we're going to
include
bioinformatics we're going to include
social sciences we're going to include
political science we're going to the
list goes on and on and on including the
humanities because I think there are
clear opportunities in the humanities
for us to be able to harness data in
order to not only do
types of active scholarly activities
that have been traditional and
Humanities but opportunities where the
humanities can inform the way we explain
our science in order to have a greater
background
our our nation and what I would call
civil discourse so I'm really excited
about this I was incredibly humbled to
be named the inaugural Dean it's a big
job starting a new school it's not
something that a university does very
often we're not exactly sure if it's
been 50 years since the last one or nine
years we're trying to track that down
but clearly it's a historical incident
and so there's no cookbook on how to do
this but I'm going to share my contact
information through Pi data triangle and
don't hesitate to reach out for a
conversation I'm sure I'm going to be
busy for a while getting the
conversations done in an orderly fashion
but I just wanted to say hello and I'm
really eager to hear you all provide
feedback from the front line so to speak
um and and tell us what what do you need
for us to train the students in I I
think my experience at renci has taught
me that we need to know we need students
who are really trained in how to go to
the cloud how to use GitHub how to you
know use Python how to use R how to use
it so it's it's a it's a it's a high
load skill set but clearly the people
this talk was fantastic thank you
we use graph databases every day in our
research and we think that that's one of
the secret ingredients and we use them
because they're highly flexible in
allowing you to hook together data
that's very disparate but yet related to
one another so with that I'll I'll maybe
answer a question or two but I think I'm
pushing the five minutes now thank you
all
and uh this is Mark uh could you could
you say something about where the school
of data science is going to be located
on campus and
um something about the Departments and
schools that current that are the big
three are the big three supporting you
so the three units that I see as and um
I'll even maybe say four units that I
see supporting uh the school supporting
is maybe not the right word it's more
partnering with the new school
um so computer science is one store
statistics is another Applied
Mathematics and biostatistics we also
want to have a very close relationship
with Sills because data science and
information in library Sciences are two
different things but there is a
considerable overlap particularly when
you start thinking about how information
affects
um Society so we we want to find close
Partnerships with those units but we
don't want to restrict ourselves to
solely those units so I've already
tonight while I was listening to the
talk which was excellent I was also
answering questions from people from
um School of Public Health is there an
opportunity for us to hire joint faculty
in that space i i fielded two or three
questions from
um other units around campus so
including centers and institutes so
we're really trying to think of this as
a pan campus effort where the
Investments and when Investments are
mentioned you always want to know where
the money's coming from I think it's
going to come from a lot of sources
we've got a small amount of money from
the legislature this year
um I don't know if that's formalized yet
but at least we have a progress and the
university is making a substantial
investment and so
um I'm I'm hoping that we can find ways
of using data as a
a unifying theme to bring together many
disciplinary expertise uh people across
the campus any indeed I have just got
off the phone or off the zoom with a
colleague over at Duke I think across
universities we want to be able to start
putting together teams that tackle
really hard daunting problems for
society including things like you know
global warming and Public Health
does that answer the question mark sure
uh when when will you start
receiving or accepting students whether
whether at the undergrad or graduate
level so it's a little bit up in the air
right now but we're shooting for in in
at least in the public statements that
uh my leadership has put out that we're
hoping to start enrolling students in
2023 I think there are students that are
on campus right now that will be
vectored through a series of courses so
that when we start to accept students
they can be early
acceptances who which have already
fulfilled some requirements again this
everything in Academia takes longer than
I would like because we have a lot of
discourse to have to conduct to be able
to find the right path but I do think
that there's a general agreement that
the school of data science and Society
is going to draw on courses that already
exist to some degree as well as hiring
new faculty
so I'm hoping that we can move pretty
quickly we already have some programs
that have been approved and have started
formation and including one at the
undergraduate level for a minor which is
currently housed in the College of Arts
and Sciences I'm meeting with the new
Dean of the College of Arts and Sciences
tomorrow and we'll work through how
we're going to cooperate on that
okay
for inviting me I very much appreciate
it and I hope you don't hesitate to
reach out to me including uh possibly
making introductions to other folks that
I should be talking to around the
triangle or even the state with writ
large
that sounds very exciting
thank you I'm excited and a little
daunted as well
I'll stand for for this lightning talk I
really appreciate it thank you
all right
um
uh Mr Peter uh if you are ready uh we
can
um go ahead and start with your
lightning talk if you don't mind yeah
yeah no no thank you very much for
having me I would like to share my
screen if that's possible
it looks like
yeah
[Music]
I'm trying to
try to do that let me know if you can
see it
yes we can thank you okay great great so
just uh to add something to what you
said in the beginning of the Meetup
about having personal meetups again as
soon as possible I'm actually pretty
glad that this one's remote since I'm uh
in Dublin Ireland uh originally actually
I'm from Budapest Hungary so even a bit
further away from you but uh I'm here to
make a talk tomorrow at the Euro python
about basically the same topic that I'm
going to talk to you about which is uh
like a series of tools that we built in
our own early stage startup called the
vizu and uh yandla was kind enough to
promise me that I might be able to do a
proper uh Meetup talk later on I still
hope that for that occasion it's going
to be remote otherwise it will be a
little harder to arrange for me
but uh to keep the long story short so
we basically uh created a generic
charting chart morphing engine
so why we did that I mean I don't have
time here to elaborate but uh but we we
did we built it from the ground up
basically uh all the different types of
charts are are based or or drawn on the
same rule set this is what allows us to
uh trans to morph from one type of chart
to the other and and that's like a
capability that we we try to build upon
some some very central point of what we
do at Vision so uh obviously the the
animation or the the the role of the
animation is is with storytelling uh and
and making people comprehend the data
stories easier so
um I mean with the four charts that I
showed you in the previous slide it's
not my so I mean just by playing this
short animation the connection between
them becomes Crystal Clear without me
having to explain anything and I'm
pretty sure those of you who have to
present your findings present your
charts to to others especially non-data
scientists I have to spend quite a lot
of time with with explaining what we see
also there are actually plenty of
benefits that the Char that the
animation brings to data visualization
and we we feel that it's pretty similar
to the the change between movies and
images so you can you know dig into
components of a composite index or or
see just parts of like basically turning
one single charge into a story see
changes over time as in a racing bar
chart and and zoom in on details uh
create context while because of the
animation the viewers Don't Lose That
kind of context when you're showing the
data from from different angles uh so we
were thinking a lot about how to to
productize this capability and basically
we we identified a crucial problem
regarding data scientists but I mean I'm
not a data scientist so you might
contradict me on this but actually based
on this resource that Anaconda released
a year ago within the state of data
science it turned out that well actually
this whole storytelling aspect and
delivering the inside so like a lot of
time is spent on it uh it's very
important for companies whereas uh still
most of the data scientists feel that
the the company leadership have a lot of
trouble understanding the stories they
tell so we started building uh towards
solving this problem we have an open
source technology the core engine is in
C plus plus we used it in-house to build
stories to demonstrate the capabilities
of our technology they get quite popular
especially on Reddit and and some other
platforms then we released a JavaScript
library for web developers last
September which got around 1500 GitHub
Stars pretty soon and a lot of positive
feedback and just like four months ago
even a little less we released our
notebook integration for data scientists
and this is called this is we we call
this to IPI Visual and I'm going to show
you some example of its use like in a
minute or so so the embeddability and
the whole open source approach that we
took allowed us to you know become
available in all these platforms uh
within three months uh if you miss any
other notebooks other platforms that you
use that you feel uh ipadvisor or visual
would be a good fit for and just let me
know in the comments I'm actually very
curious about that we're working on the
Streamlight integration as we speak
so yeah let's go let me show you uh like
a super simple example of how this whole
thing works so this is like a story that
I've put together we use pandas
obviously uh so if I run this cell
nothing really happens but we uh just
initiate everything and load the data a
CSV file in this case to the data frame
uh just to show you what's in there it's
basically some bogus sales data from a
company that has four different regions
four different products with sales and
revenue data and so to draw a chart in
visual you can set the width and height
of it and then you have to initialize it
and then you basically just add the data
and and here we filter it so first we're
gonna see the shoes and then we put the
series like the region on the x-axis and
you know this is this is what we do here
and just by running this cell uh the
chart appears this is this is a vanilla
Jupiter notebook I just use a special
type of CSS to to show the the results
and the code side by side and so in the
next phase uh the the only thing we do
is we we add handbags to the mix so we
modify the filter and as you can see
visual will already animate between the
states and then you can see the shoes
next to the handbags then we're gonna
add the third category of products which
are gloves so here we modify the filter
that it doesn't include accessories and
then at the last stage we just add
the accessories
so we have the sales number of all
products per every region but obviously
it's not only about how many items you
sell but also how much revenue you've
got and in order to change that we will
just switch the revenue on the y-axis
and also on the label and then change
the title accordingly and so it is a
really important uh match so to see how
the chart changes and you know obviously
there are plenty of things that changed
here uh because because uh yeah the the
the the the revenue results are pretty
different from product results and then
we can just uh with calling the animate
function twice or method twice this time
uh we will just rearrange the chart in a
way that it Aggregates all the data
independently from the regions and shows
it on the chart
so it's it's like I I don't know how
many animated charts have you made
before uh according to like what I've
heard from other data scientists uh it's
it's not that easy to do it with other
tools especially in Python so uh you can
find it on GitHub uh it's called ipivizu
we prepared with the step-by-step
tutorial and plenty of examples uh for
you to to start using it I mean if you
look at the examples you have the static
charts here you even have animated
charts and you can click on any of those
and yeah the animations are not visual
but some video that that can be lagging
when especially when I let's share my
screen and so if you click on any of
those you'll get to the code
and uh and and you you'll be able to to
understand how the chart was created so
we are actually as an early stage
startup very keen on further developing
what we do uh in order to fulfill the
expectations and so I'm actually very
very happy to present something that I
originally intended to announce just
tomorrow for the Euro python conference
audience but since I got this chance I
had to tell you that we added two
crucial features now first one is that
we are going to have presets so this is
the JavaScript version I'm sorry about
that my studio is our studio is actually
working hard around the clock so it's
past midnight back in Hungary to make it
available for the ipadvisor
documentation but basically and we have
some issues here with the title but
basically now you're going to be able to
just determine the type of the chart
that you want to to build and then add
what's required to that specific chart
type because we heard that it's easier
than just using the generic engine that
that is behind uh with you or that power
species and the other very very
important new feature that we're going
to add is called ipadvisor story here is
an example of it it's almost the same
code but we have some a story object
here and some slides but as you can see
within the slides it's basically the
same type of code that you saw before
and so at the bottom of the notebook you
have this tank and this is already a
fully fledged presentation that you can
use to present your findings an animated
presentation that you can move like back
and forth
between predetermined steps even with
your keyboard even with a clicker so it
means that whatever you found in Jupiter
and want to show your peers we hope it's
going to be much easier to share and and
present this way and it's going to be
much easier obviously for them to
comprehend what's going on
so uh this is all that I I wanted to
share with you for today uh obviously
this is also on ipadvisor story we just
released it like yeah six hours ago uh
so it's it's it's uh fresh out of the
oven I'm pretty sure it's gonna be a
little bit rough around the edges but um
uh I still hope you're gonna like it
uh I'd be happy to take any questions
actually if you can pay a visit to
arapos and drop us a star I would
definitely appreciate that and
for those of you who have to do this
kind of thing so like present the
results of their findings ad hoc
analysis and things like that if you
could just go to this link right now and
spend like two minutes filling out a
short and sweet survey about uh
you know how how is it going for you
that would enable us to to learn a lot
and and I would definitely appreciate
that so I hope I'm not out of time here
and uh yeah I'm happy to take uh
any any questions that you might have
it's just so strange I can't see I can't
see anyone so I'm talking to my screen
here
Bravo presentation I mean uh lightning
talk Peter I really like it
um yeah I believe in a chat
um uh several of us uh expressed you
know big interest in learning this uh
iPad Visa uh you know in your uh open
source GitHub uh Repository
pretty pretty cool thank you thank you
very much so this is my contacts and let
me just uh really quickly copy and paste
here uh the the links for the two
repositories and also I know I know I
know people hate surveys and I
understand and they understandably do
but I can promise you it's gonna be
short and sweet and and you can help us
so so much so uh pretty please if you
can just have two minutes of your time
seems like if I copy and paste that here
it's gonna end up with a very strange
Bond so let me do a little bit of
removing the you know
okay yeah this this one works yeah I did
not know Peter you are located all the
um uh so far away from uh triangle in
the United States
where is your location again don't mind
I'm no no absolutely not so I am right
now in Belfast Ireland I'm sure you've
heard about this city
uh and uh originally I'm from Budapest
Hungary it's a central eastern Europe uh
so I here it's only like half past
midnight back at home it's already half
past one in the morning
thank you so much for you know um
you know be with us you know I didn't
know we have different time zones uh now
I know yeah so appreciated no I'm I'm
Andrea I'm glad to be here and you know
this is let's say the upside of having a
virtual meet up so it would have been a
hell a lot more different to to get
there you know and uh to you but
obviously a more uh full experience uh
to get to know you but I'm still very
glad and and I hope I'll have a chance
to
um you know make it make a proper
presentation about what we do and why we
came up with this whole concept of the
generic charting engine and all this
stuff
but thanks again for having me
absolutely absolutely thank you Peter I
will definitely let you know
um we'll facilitate a
uh for you to to you know to give us a
full presentation we're very looking
forward to that thank you young life
thank you very much
alrighty um
I think we are uh we have gone over 10
minutes but I think we had really good
time I hope you guys had a really good
time in this event tried a triangle Pi
data event in July so